hello my name is Dustin Kirkland I'm a
product manager at Google and I'm joined
here by Lukas Heinrich he's a physicist
at CERN and has some pre-and exciting
experiment that he reproduced using
cloud technology and he's going to tell
us a bit about that yeah so during the
keynote we rediscovered the Higgs boson
using a publicly available data set and
during a keynote we launched 25,000
workloads on the public cloud to analyze
collision data of the Large Hadron
Collider and there we selected events
where we had a pretty good chance that
the Higgs boson was originally there and
during the keynote you could see a chart
building up where in the middle of the
chart there was a small peak forming and
that peak more or less proved the
existence of the Higgs boson it's
fascinating so you work on the Atlas
project and with the Atlas project you
were working on some data from CERN and
I understand this has some parallels to
what we do in the open source community
right so many of the experiments at CERN
have an open data policy so which means
that data that we record we release it
openly and so I work at the Atlas
project but the data that we used in the
demo was from the CMS project which is a
project is very similar to mine and it
kind of exemplifies that even me who is
not a member of the CMS project I can
analyze this data from them because they
released it openly and in fact anybody
thanks to these cloud resources anybody
can do it one of the challenges and open
data for these large-scale scientific
collaborations has always said the data
the scale of the data is very large and
while we can release it it was always a
bit of a question who can practically
analyze it who doesn't have a data
center and how large is very is pret is
practically large data so that we
analyze yesterday in the span of a few
minutes or 70 terabytes 70 terabytes
it's not even practical for me to
download that and try to store that at
home on a laptop in a university but
this can be found now in in the cloud
right so we have it available at CERN
the open data and then we transferred it
because we have high-speed links to
the club providers we transferred it
into a Google Cloud storage and this is
from where we read the data to analyze
it and now anybody could in principle do
that so student another University
another organization anyone can work on
that data without downloading it right
and where do you see this going next
give us some idea of how these these
methods and and Google Cloud can be used
for for your research so I think what's
super exciting is that this open data
originally oftentimes was seen as
something for outrage or educational
purposes that you have really small
scale data sets and but now researchers
are starting to really use it for a real
scientific applications outside of the
experiment so people who have nothing to
do with the Large Hadron Collider they
can analyze this data that we release
openly I think that is pretty exciting
cool and which what's your next project
so one thing that I really want to try
out in the cloud ecosystem is functions
as a service so this is something that
kind of fits well on to our workload
that we showed yesterday and so will
maybe go back home and try to though
cloud run Kay native on top of
kubernetes and exactly tell me a little
bit about your next project what are you
working on next and how do you see using
Google Cloud so I think what was pretty
exciting is the release of cloud run a
couple of weeks ago and so the workload
that we showed yesterday during a demo
actually would fit nicely into this
functions as a service paradigm and
maybe when we get home we'll try this
out and see whether or not we can run
the demo in this way yeah that's
fascinating I would imagine those batch
type services really match to the work
that you're doing so the data
transformations were so the data that we
download it's in one form and then we
process and produce a summary format and
so this is essentially a function Thank
You Lucas appreciate your time
[Music]
[Music]